the giant Squid's sheer size strength
speed and hunting abilities would make
it extremely difficult to
escape the first stealthy move it would
make is attacking you from
below o horrifying right well it gets
worse the giant squid probably isn't
going to devour you right then and there
it's going to drag you into deep water
where it feels safe from its own
Predators because it's so fast you would
definitely struggle with the changing
pressure and your eard drums would
certainly burst this Speedy Whiplash may
also break some of your bones from the
giant squid holding you so
tight if you're somehow Not Dead by
being gripped and scraped by the feeding
tentacles the giant squid would use all
of its arms to bring you to its beak